- Early on before the
league got shut down,
the team had brought a doctor in
to talk to everybody,
tell everybody,
okay, this is happening,
a little bit about it.
And one of the first
things he said was,
masks do absolutely nothing.
And he was like,
I'm just letting you guys know
that apparently the way
he phrased it was like,
I guess the COVID
particles were so small
that they could pass through,
pretty much most masks,
especially cloth mask.
- Yeah.
- So that was our first thing.
So when he first said that,
I was like, okay, I'm
not wearing a mask.
And then you have these mask
mandates and things like that.
I'm like, what is going on?
And so, yeah,
it was pretty crazy.
And in the bubble,
a lot of things
didn't make sense,
but we kind of just
went along with it
because we wanted to play.
(bright music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today is a
professional basketball player
for the Orlando Magic and
author of the new book,
"Why I Stand," Jonathan Isaac,
welcome to the Ruben Report.
- What's up, Dave.
Man, I'm excited to be here.
Excited to talk to you.
Let's go.
- All right, let's do it.
This is sort of your second
time on the Ruben Report
because I was in
Orlando back in,
what was it?
That was end of October.
And I was doing
this NatCon event.
And I was like, hey,
Jonathan, Isaac's in Orlando.
Maybe I can drag him on stage.
And then you spoke in front
of about 500 conservatives.
That was a little odd for you,
but you pretty much
brought the house down.
- But it was weird.
You know, first
time kind of even,
I mean, outside of like church,
but like really speaking
in front of people
and then it being,
a conservative event.
It was dope though.
You know, everybody was great.
I had a great time just
learning and listening.
And you had the
chance to talk to you
and kind of just continue
to push forward my message.
- So let's start off with
some basketball stuff,
'cause you know that my dream
was to be an NBA player.
You accomplished my dream
and you're pretty
good at what I do.
That's what I said
to you on stage.
You could be doing the
talking thing for a living.
But you made it to the NBA
and we also have
something else in common.
We both have a torn ACL.
So that has taken you out
for these last two seasons.
Is left or right knee for you?
- Left knee.
- Left knee for me too.
Tell me a little bit
about just growing
up playing hoops.
Did you always
wanna be in the NBA?
Did you think you could
make it to the NBA?
Just the challenges there
before we get into
the book specifically.
- Yeah. I mean the
book does a great job
of just telling that
story of growing up
in Bronx, New York,
and playing at the rec center
in the park with my dad.
And there is when
I really just kind
of like fell in
love with the game,
not so much scoring
and all that stuff.
Just the art of watching guys,
do what they do on
the basketball court.
I was like, man, it's so cool
to watch them go left to right
and all these different things.
But I didn't know
anything about basketball
and the grand scheme of things.
So nothing about college,
nothing about the NBA,
nothing about conferences.
There's one story in the book
where I'm getting recruited
to go to college to play ball.
And the coach is saying,
do you know what
conference we're in?
And I'm like, well,
what's a conference?
(Dave chuckles)
And I think that really speaks
to how much I didn't even think
that it could be a
possibility for me
to get to the NBA.
So it really, to me,
is like a God thing
that I'm here,
'cause I never believed in it.
And so yeah,
I mean I fell in love with it.
I pretty much put everything
that I had into it,
became the number one player
in the state of Florida,
coming getting outta
high school to college
and then was a six
pick to Orlando Magic.
- Did you always
have great skills
or was it kind of learned
or a little bit of both?
- I say all learned really.
Like, yeah, I love to
watch the guys on the TV,
but I could never do anything
like that in the court.
The first time I got
to play on an AAU team,
they kicked me off of the
team without even telling me.
And that's how bad I was.
And so, my ride to practice
just stopped coming
to pick me up.
But it was definitely learned.
Like I got my first coach
that really was like
taking an interest in me
because of my size, was Bora,
and he's in the book as well.
And you know, he
was the first one
to teach me the
fundamentals and develop.
And from there I kind of,
it was just like riding a bike.
I kind of just,
because I was watching so much
and I found that passion in
liking the way that guys move
that kind of just picked it up
and kind of went from there.
- Were you tall immediately
or late spurt or what?
- I had a decent, like I guess,
like a journey of a spurt.
It wasn't all at one time.
But I was always,
more so the biggest
person in my class,
especially through
the younger years.
Once I got to high school,
I was probably six foot,
6'1 my freshman year.
And then each year,
I jumped up three or four inches
and then I got to seven foot.
- Who are your heroes,
basketball heroes growing up?
Who were the guys
that you were like,
oh man, I wanna do that.
I wanna model it after that.
- You know, I loved KD.
You know, great players still.
But it's different now,
being able to play against them.
But yeah, I love the fact
that he was such a big player,
but was a guard pretty much.
And so him, Dirk, PG,
guys that I watch all the time.
And I think I watched KD before
every high school game,
before every college game.
Yeah.
- And tell me about that moment.
You get the you're
at draft night
and they say your name,
and your life changes
(Dave snaps)
just like that.
- Yeah, it was awesome.
But for me, it was weird
because everybody else around me
seemed like they knew
what was going on.
Like they were ready
for the moment they had,
what they were
gonna do afterwards.
They were gonna go party.
They were gonna go celebrate
with their families.
Like everyone took it in stride.
But for me it was like,
I don't know what to do.
So I kind of, just
after I got drafted,
I walked to a pizza
shop down the street.
It was in New York
with coach Gates,
who's a big part of my life.
And one of my agents assistants
and we got a pizza and I
went back to the hotel room,
and sent my parent, my
family home on an Uber,
and then went in my room.
It was kind of just like a,
it was weird.
I didn't know,
it just all went
by so fast as well.
- And it must have been
pretty sweet for you.
As you said,
you played ball in Florida
then to be drafted by Orlando,
you get to keep it in Florida,
and you seem to have a great
connection with the state.
- Yeah.
I love the state of Florida
and I've come to appreciate
it more and more,
especially as the world has
gotten crazier and crazier.
So, you know,
I'm a fan of DeSantis and
what he is been able to do,
but yeah, I love Florida.
I'm, I'm glad that I'm here.
I feel like it's a God Dame
thing for me to be here
from middle school till now.
And you know, I love the state.
- All right.
So let's, let's pick
it up right there.
'Cause you mentioned DeSantis
and then the Florida situation.
And what put you
on my radar was,
it's gotta be almost
two years ago now.
Pretty early on
into the pandemic,
NBA was one of the first leagues
that just completely
shut down outta nowhere.
In some ways,
it was the first big
thing that did it,
that then led to so many other
institutions closing down.
You were one of the first
guys out there that was like,
hey, could we slow
down with some of this?
Or maybe I don't wanna
be necessarily injected
with this thing
or I'm gonna make some
choices for myself,
et cetera, et cetera.
So first, could you just
talk a little bit about
what it was like
when you were hearing
that things were gonna change
and that the league was
shutting down before it got,
'cause it all didn't
happen at once.
That the vaccine stuff
started happening
a little bit later than that.
- Right.
So I think what
happened at first
was everybody was
just so afraid.
Like right we were
getting those photos
from China and some videos
and stuff like that.
It was like, this thing
is coming to America.
You know, when is
it gonna pop up?
There was cases.
And then you hear that a
player in the NBA has it
and had spread it
to his teammates.
And so, because of the way
that it was portrayed
in the media.
It was just such a fearful time.
I feel like everybody was
walking on egg shells,
thinking about when
they were gonna get it.
And so once the
NBA had shut down,
we had time to kind of just,
now I think we went on
a quarantine really,
I think right around that time,
at least Florida
had like a curfew.
It wasn't a complete lockdown,
but we had a curfew that
you had to be in your house.
And it was just a weird time.
But you know, social
media wasn't a big help
because of all the things
that were spreading
and going around.
And so, I just tried my best
to try to take a step back
and just watch everything.
There was an early
hesitation with me
because of the way that
things were being portrayed.
It seemed like
everything was so forced
and made to be
fearful for everyone
to kind of be running
around like chickens
with their head cuts off.
So I kind of just took
a step back and said,
let me watch.
And then we get to the bubble.
And then after that,
we get to, okay,
now there's a
vaccine on the scene
and that's that we
get a little later.
- Right.
So, all right.
Let's talk about the
bubble situation.
'Cause I think people
or people that don't
pay attention to the NBA
that are watching us,
don't even know what that is.
But they basically had you guys
in your own sort of lockdown,
so that the season could
kind of somewhat continue
and sometimes you'd
have masks on the bench,
but then you take
them off to play.
So now you're
sweating on each other
and spitting on each other
and probably bleeding
on each other.
But then when you sit down,
you're wearing the mask.
I mean, none of it
really made sense.
Did coaches and
players talk about
kind of the craziness
of the whole thing?
- Yeah, we definitely did.
And I think,
especially early on,
like when we were first
getting into the bubble,
everyone still, the
world is so afraid.
So the NBA and all these
different organizations
are trying to do all that
they can to kind of like,
okay, we need to focus
on this and tackle this,
but at the same time
we need guys to play.
So what can we do?
Okay.
They wear the mask on the bench
and they go into the
game and take it off.
But it was such hysteria
and just things
weren't making sense.
And so, we definitely
had conversations
about needing to test every
day and the mask thing.
You know, early on before
the league got shut down,
the team had brought a doctor in
to talk to everybody,
tell everybody,
okay, this is happening,
a little bit about it.
And one of the first
things he said was,
masks do absolutely nothing.
(Dave chuckles)
And he was like,
I'm just letting you guys
know that apparently,
the way he phrased it was like,
I guess the COVID
particles were so small
that they could pass through
pretty much most masks,
especially cloth mask.
- Yeah.
- So that was our first thing.
So when he first said that,
I was like, okay,
I'm not wearing a mask.
And then you have
these mask mandates
and things like that.
I'm like, what is going on?
And so, yeah.
It was pretty crazy
in the bubble.
A lot of things
didn't make sense,
but we kind of just
went along with it
because we wanted to play.
- Were you surprised the way
some guys just kind
of took the orders,
even though they
thought it didn't work,
or the fact that
you guys are mostly
in your mid twenties
at the peak of physical health,
like your
cardiovascular is better
than basically
anyone on the planet.
You all eat right,
et cetera, et cetera,
yet everybody started
doing all this crazy stuff.
- I wouldn't say
I was surprised.
I mean, societal
pressure is tough.
I mean, it works.
And especially when you have
people that are higher up
or just people
around you who are,
who kind of adopt this
mainstream idea or ideology
and kind of just run with it.
So I don't think
I was surprised.
Even myself early on,
I was like, okay, this
is what we have to do.
It wasn't until
things got later on
and we get out the bubble,
and then the vaccine
starts coming around.
And then I can just see the,
just how much it
was being pushed.
And you have all the
people on social media,
the demeaning everyone
and all this stuff.
And then, the thing about
the Rolling Stone article
happens to me.
And that's when I'm like,
okay, this thing is really
not just about a vaccine.
It's political,
there's an agenda.
There's a bias to it.
But I, no,
I wouldn't surprise everybody
kind of went along with it.
- All right.
So let's get to that
part in just a sec,
but I just wanna do a
little more on the bubble.
So again, for people
that don't know,
so they basically had you guys,
were you all pretty
much in one hotel
and had to limit who
was coming in and out?
Like they really,
the idea was that you
weren't gonna basically
see anybody else,
wives, kids, et cetera,
and that you would play
against each other,
and that's it.
But I've heard from
some other players,
that's not exactly
how the thing worked.
- Well, it was three hotels.
And so you had teams split
up in these three hotels
and pretty much
the order was like,
you're not allowed to leave.
Once you come in, that's it.
As the bubble kind of went on
and we got to the playoffs,
I think they allowed some
people's families to come in
or just their wives or
something like that.
But early on, it
was like strict.
We test every day.
I think we were testing
like twice a day.
I'm not even really sure,
but you're testing every day.
You know, they had
a lounge set up,
they had a barbershop for.
So they tried to kind of
help it be worthwhile,
but it was just tough to kind
of just be in the hotel
room all the time.
But yeah, nothing in,
nothing out of food all there.
So it was really
like a jail lowkey.
- I mean, I heard some rumors
that people were
coming and going,
and able to get some lady
friends inside et cetera.
- And some people
got in trouble.
You know, some people
who got caught,
I didn't hear anything
about guys actually being
successful with that,
but I did hear the story
about one guy trying
and getting in trouble.
- Right.
- So, okay.
So then the bubble passes
and now things start
shifting towards the vaccine.
And that's where
that video of you.
What month?
Do you remember
what month that was?
- No, not at all.
- All right.
So it's about a
year and a half ago.
I mean, it was at the
height of the whole thing.
And basically, you
gave a spectacular,
you know what?
We'll lay it in right here.
We're gonna lay in
the speech right here,
so people can listen to it.
- It is my belief that the
vaccine status of every person
should be their own choice
and completely up to them
without bullying,
without being pressured
or without being
forced into doing so.
I'm not ashamed to say
that I'm uncomfortable
with taking the
vaccine at this time.
I think that we're
all different.
We all come from
different places.
We've all had
different experiences
and hold dear to
different beliefs.
And what it is that
you do with your body,
when it comes to putting
medicine in there,
should be your choice,
free of the ridicule and
the opinion of others.
I've had COVID in the past.
And so, our understanding
of antibodies,
of natural immunity,
has changed a great deal
from the onset of the pandemic,
and it's still evolving.
I understand that the
vaccine would help
if you catch COVID
and you'll be able
to have less symptoms
from contracting it.
But with me having
COVID in the past,
and to having antibodies
with my current age group
and physical fitness level,
it's not necessarily
a fear of mine,
taking the vaccine.
Like I said,
it would decrease my chances
of having a severe reaction,
but it does open me up to
the albeit rare chance,
but the possibility of
having an adverse reaction
to the vaccine itself.
I don't believe that being
unvaccinated means infected
or being vaccinated
means uninfected.
You can still catch COVID
with or with not
having the vaccine.
I would say honestly,
the craziness of it all
in terms of not
being able to say
that it should be
everybody's fair choice
without being demeaned
or talked crazy to,
doesn't make one comfortable
to do what that person is,
telling them to do.
Yeah.
I would say, that's a
couple of the reasons
that I would say I'm
hesitant at this time.
But at the end of the day,
I don't feel that it is.
You know, anyone's reason
to come out and say,
well, this is why,
or this is not why it should
just be their decision.
And you know, loving
your neighbors,
not just loving those
that agree with you,
or look like you are moving
the same way that you do.
It's loving those who don't.
- So that right there.
I mean, you laid out
more common sense,
decency, and thoughtful analysis
than pretty much
anything I saw on CNN.
And that's where I was like,
man, I gotta talk to this guy.
- Yeah. I mean, so
again, like early on,
like me just trying
to take a step back
and just see everything
that was going on.
I was like, okay,
they're saying that the virus
has a 99.97 survival rate.
I'm young, you know,
people who are older
and have comorbidities
or obese are really
struggling with this thing.
So I just said, you know,
as I saw how much the
vaccine was being pushed
and forced on everybody,
and then you see social
media and people,
calling people crazy for
not wanting to take it,
or even just being hesitant
or asking questions.
And then you have
people's medical
and religious
exemptions being denied,
and people losing their jobs.
I was like, man, this is insane.
This isn't right.
And so I just said,
you know what,
I'm young, I'm healthy.
I don't have any side effects
or anything like that.
I don't see the wisdom
in putting something
into my body.
That's not gonna stop me
from getting the virus
or transmitting it
to someone else.
That's just where I'm at
and I'm not gonna do it.
And you know, at the same time,
I want it to be a hope
and a voice for other people
who are going through this,
who didn't have a platform.
- Was that just a normal
postgame press conference?
Or were you planning
on doing that?
Or how did that even happen?
Were you thinking about,
hey, I gotta say something.
- No, it was actually perfect
because the Rolling
Stone article.
So, if around that time,
the team calls me and they say,
hey, you know, the
Rolling Stone wants to do
an interview with you about
everything that's going on.
I'm saying, cool.
So I get on the phone
with him and he's like,
you're unvaccinated.
And I'm thinking to myself like,
how do you even know
that I'm unvaccinated?
Whatever.
- Welcome to the mainstream
media, my friend.
- Right.
But, yeah, it was actually
a great conversation.
Like we're talking
and he's like,
oh, you know what?
I agree with you
on that and all,
that's a good point.
And I pretty much
laid out to him
exactly what I went on
to say the next day.
And so, but the article
drops that night,
like the Sunday night.
And it says,
Jonathan Isaac came to his
vaccination status, whatever,
by watching Donald
Trump press conferences
and studying black history.
And that's when I'm
like, oh my gosh.
- Yep.
- And everybody's on social
media calling me crazy.
And I sound stupid
in the article.
But the next day was media day.
So Monday is media day.
And I was expecting
the question.
I was on the phone with
my pastor that night.
And he was like,
well, you have an
opportunity to talk
about it tomorrow at media day,
have to ask you about it.
And I just kind of tried
to lay it out there.
- Yeah.
So that was your
first time being hit
by the media like that, huh?
Welcome to the party.
- Well, it was my first,
not being hit by the media
because then you have the whole
standing in the bubble thing
that was before that.
That was in June of 2020.
But it was the first time like-
- Oh, right.
So yeah, wait, let's back up.
Tell people about
that first, right.
We skipped over something big.
- Well, yeah.
Well, so around the time of
what happened to George Floyd,
as tragic and as
wrong as it was,
there was a lot of
pressure on NBA players
going into the bubble,
to have to kneel for
the national anthem
and the wear the Black
Lives Matter T-shirt.
But again, I same
thing with the vaccine,
I tried to step back and say,
okay, what is the right way
for me to respond in this moment
that I feel would
bring real change?
And for some people
in that moment,
it was kneeling and
wearing the t-shirt.
But for me, it wasn't.
And so, I looked at my life
and said, you know what?
My life has been
supported and changed
by the gospel of Jesus Christ.
And I don't see
a greater message
or a greater anecdote
or hope for the times
that we see ourselves in racism.
And not even that,
just all the things that
plague the hearts of men
that I know that the
gospel can change.
I wanted to stand up
and give that message.
I didn't wanna go with
anybody's narrative
or the whole,
as crazy as the whole Black
Lives Matter movement was.
I didn't wanna kind
of just fall into it.
And so I decided to be
the only one to stand
and to share that message
of loving your neighbor,
the way that you
were gonna be loved.
- Did the team know what you
were gonna do on that day
when you decided to stand
and everybody else kneeled?
- So there's a lot of details
in the book that I explained.
Like, I called somebody that
was in the Magic organization
the night before.
'Cause I didn't wanna
catch 'em off guard.
So I called them
and we had a whole team
meeting the day before.
So we had a team meeting
and the executives of the team,
came in and said, you know what?
We support you guys on
whatever you decide to do.
A team had already
knelt earlier that day.
And so they were like,
you were gonna
give you guys time
to just talk about it as a team,
so they walked out.
And the guys were just like,
yo, we don't have a choice.
This is what we have to do.
We have to kneel.
We can't be only
team that doesn't.
And then one of my teammates
looking me and they say,
yo, Jonathan, what
are you gonna do?
Like, they kind of
knew, I don't know why.
But he's like, what
are you gonna do?
I said, fellas, I'm not
gonna wear that t-shirt
and I'm not gonna kneel
for the national anthem.
And then I called somebody
in the Magic
organization that night
and kind of let 'em know.
And they just said, okay.
We'll handle it tomorrow.
- In retrospect,
I mean, were you thinking,
man, like this could cause all
kinds of problems, you know?
I mean, look, what's going on
with Enes Kanter right now,
the guys in the
prime of his career,
he can't get a contract.
I mean, that it just
creates headaches.
That even if you have all the
skills and everything else,
the teams are just like,
I don't wanna deal
with the headache.
Everyone else is going along.
And that's the type of
people we want with us.
- Look the night before I stood,
I was on the phone
with my pastor
and I was letting him know.
I was like, yo,
I don't think you understand
how big this is gonna be.
Like, you know, people
are getting canceled.
I didn't sign my contract yet.
I didn't sign my
contract extension.
So they would,
and the possibility of
me getting canceled,
then I wouldn't
have the contract
that I have right now.
But yeah, I knew the
backlash that was gonna come.
I knew, you know the
Coon and the uncle Tom.
I know the people who
would automatically take it
and make it about the flag
in the national anthem,
and all that stuff.
I knew all that
stuff was gonna come.
But at the same time,
the one thing that my
pastor said to me is,
you cannot stand for God
and God cannot stand for you.
And so, I knew what
I was standing for.
I wasn't standing
for a movement.
I wasn't standing for a side.
I was standing to
offer that message
that we all fall
show to God's glory,
every single one of us.
And with anyone to throw stones
or throwing stones
from a glass house.
And so, while I try my best,
those just kind of come
from a humble position
and say, man, if we
could love each other,
the way that God loves us,
which is in spite of our sin,
in spite of our faults,
then we could really
change the world.
- What about some
of your teammates?
It sounds like
maybe some of them
kind of wanted to do the same,
but felt the pressure
and just couldn't bear it?
- Well at the time,
I didn't know that.
And I wouldn't even say
my teammates per se,
but I had conversations
with other guys
around the league and
even in other sports.
So after I had left the bubble,
I hurt myself the next game.
I tore my ACL the next game.
And I got a call from a
soccer player here in Orlando.
And he was like, hey,
I saw what you did.
I wanna do the same thing,
but I'm terrified.
And this is a white guy.
So he's extra terrified.
(Both chuckles)
And so, you know,
I was able to talk
him through it
and encourage him to stand up
for what he believes in.
But you know, it was a
very emotional moment.
And so I was expecting
guys on my team
to disagree with me.
I was even expecting
it to get heated.
And so, you know,
details in the book,
there's a team meeting that
happens the day after I stood.
And it's a heated conversation
between me and the guys.
But it pretty much ends with,
look, you guys know for
what you believed in.
And I stood for
what I believed in.
It wasn't a protest
for you guys,
I protest,
it was just because
I see the same things
that you guys see,
but I don't believe that the
Black Lives Matter organization
or kneeling for
the national anthem
and wearing a t-shirt
is the answer.
- What's your take on just sort
of how generally sports
has become so politicized?
I mentioned to you when
I saw you in Orlando,
I grew up the biggest NBA
fan you can ever imagine.
I mean, basketball,
I love basketball as much
as you love basketball,
but I don't really
watch anymore.
I just don't watch because
it became so politicized.
Every time I turn
on an NBA game,
all they're doing is
talking about basketball,
talking about,
I wish they were talking
about basketball.
They're talking about politics
or they got the BLM logo out,
or they're analyzing
some race event.
And I'm just like,
man, I can't take it anymore.
Are the players
talking about that too?
Is there some level
of frustration
that you guys aren't just
focused on basketball?
- No, I haven't had that
conversation with any players.
And I know that
it's something that,
a large part of
America has felt.
And I think it's
just unfortunate.
I think things
like organizations
like the NBA or anything
that's in the
entertainment phrase,
it only benefits them to
be in the middle ground.
But I think because of,
maybe one group or
one side being able
to frame the argument
and make it a moraL argument
on a lot of the things
that are happening,
take the vaccine, take BLM.
To where if you disagree,
you're an evil person.
And so it's easy
for them to kind
of take that moral
high ground and say,
this is the only way,
this is the right way
to handle something.
But again,
I think it would be in the
best interest of the NBA
or any organization to just say,
we should be in the middle
and we should allow people
to watch us and enjoy.
And if an individual player
wants to use their platform
to speak on something,
I think that they should have
the absolute right to like,
I'm doing right now.
So if anybody in league
wants to stand up
and say that that was wrong
or use their
individual platform,
that's great.
But I think the NBA
should try their best
to kind of be in the middle.
- I agree.
So, all right.
So you stand for
the national anthem,
then you give this
incredible talk
at the post game on
media day about the vax.
You get some strange
media reaction.
Were you kind of surprised
where you were welcomed
and where you were kind
of shunned after that?
(Jonathan chuckles)
- No, I wouldn't say
that I was surprised.
I definitely, because you know,
it was during the
national anthem,
so there's a side of the Al
that is gonna embrace that.
And even, the overwhelming
support of Christians
and everybody that agree
with me on that front.
So I wasn't surprised at all
about the calls that I got
and the different
media personalities
that wanted to talk
to me afterwards.
I would say the only thing
that I maybe was
surprised of was that,
maybe nobody on the
other side wanted
to even have a conversation.
And I think just in the way
that I kind of
phrased my argument
or the way I went about it,
I would've made
more people to say,
you know what?
Well, let's just talk about it.
You know, I wasn't
somebody that was saying.
You know, you guys are
wrong and this is terrible.
And I didn't come
from that standpoint.
And so, I would've
definitely been open
to having more conversations
with the other side.
But, you know,
I went where I was welcome
and I just tried
my best to continue
to push that Christ first
message and go from there.
- So let's talk about
the faith part of this.
'Cause obviously,
you've mentioned your
faith a few times,
it's clearly a key
part of your life.
Were you always a believer?
Did your family come from a
deep religious background?
- So I wasn't always a believer,
but we grew up in church
when we were young
like all the time.
We were always in church.
But then I moved from Bronx,
New York to Naples, Florida,
and my parents split up.
And my dad was like my hero,
but he was really like
the spiritual foundation
of our family.
And so I went from a
predominantly black neighborhood
to a predominantly
white neighborhood.
And I really, really
struggled with fitting in.
And so I tell in the book
a couple of early instances
about just how terrible I was
at getting the other
kids to like me.
And early on,
I developed a nickname Ethiopia,
because I was so skinny and
then obviously, dark skinned.
And so, it was the first time
that I became really
self-conscious.
Like in the New York,
everybody was the same.
It was fun.
But once I got to Naples,
I was like,
I always tried so hard to fit in
and to kind of work for
the love of my peers
that I started to
develop anxiety,
I started to develop fear,
and then I found basketball.
And I was able to kind of put
everything into basketball.
And that brought me to people,
the girls that wanted
to be around me,
the guys that wanted
to be around me.
I started to make those
friends and those peers,
but I still struggle with
those things in the background.
And so, I get to Florida state,
I'm the number one player
in the state of Florida.
Everybody's expecting me
to be this great player
that takes 'em to
the championship,
but I'm still struggling
with these things
behind the scenes.
And so I have anxiety
attacks while I'm on campus.
And I passed out in class and
all these different things.
And everybody's like,
what is going on with you?
But for me,
and it really is a
wild story in the book.
I get to the NBA.
I'm living my life.
I'm doing my thing.
And then I get
injured and I guilt.
I'm at my apartment and
I get on the elevator,
and that guy stops me.
And he says, I can tell
you how to be great.
And I said, tell
me how to be great.
I'm Jonathan, Isaac,
what do you mean?
He's like, you gotta know Jesus.
And I'm like, Jesus, man.
Like I grew up Christian
and all this stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But from that point on,
like my life really does
get flipped upside down.
And it really is a story
of just like God
revealing himself to me
and like these
crazy coincidences.
And ultimately,
I was able to take a
step back and say like,
God loves me for me.
He loves me in spite of
my right and my wrong,
and I don't have to
work for his love.
And that was the
first time developing
that relationship with Christ,
where I was able to breathe
and kind of just let
my shoulders sink.
Like I don't have to
work for his love.
And I've kind of just
gone down that path
of developing a
relationship with him.
And here in Orlando,
my home church, J.U.M.P.
Ministries Global Church.
And the story really
does bring to life,
all those details and
those intricate details.
I don't wanna give too much away
because I want people
to go grab them.
- Oh, we're gonna link to
the book right down below,
don't worry about that.
How has your faith been
challenged by the injury?
Because it's sort
of the nightmare
of a professional athlete.
You blow out the knee,
you blow out the Achilles,
etcetera, etcetera.
I mean, you're going
through that right now.
It's been two full seasons.
- Yeah.
It's been tough
and it was really
tough early on.
But I'm so grateful that I have,
I just feel like I have
the right people around me.
Like my pastor,
Dr. Duran Hepburn,
he's like the angel of the book.
He's a star in the book
and me coming to faith.
He's actually the one that
stopped me in that elevator
and said that to me.
He's big.
I mean, my wife is
big, my church family.
But it was definitely tough.
Like, you know, asking God,
like why did you
allow that to happen?
Like, what's the cause?
But now that I'm able to
kind of take a step back
and see that this book is
tangible and it's alive,
and people are reading it,
and saying how inspired
and encouraged they are.
There wouldn't be a book,
if I didn't get injured.
I wouldn't have
had time to do it.
There wouldn't have been
really no inspiration
to do it outside of just,
wanting to write a story
about standing in the bubble.
But the book is so
much more than that.
The book is really a
journey about my life
and overcoming fear and anxiety,
and how a relationship with
Christ helped me to do that.
And so, it really is
just pointing people
to what I believe is truly
gonna change the world,
which is the love of Christ.
And so, I feel that it
was necessary for me
to be able to write this book.
- How does the faith part play
into just even being in rehab
and going through the pain,
going through the surgery,
all that stuff.
I mean, I told you,
my doc wants me to
have the surgery.
Obviously, I'm
not an NBA player,
but I've been
prolonging this thing
and I don't really wanna do it.
And I got PRP in my knee
and it's feeling pretty good.
But just the process,
'cause how long are
you just laid out
when you have the ACL
surgery just fully in bed?
- It was a while.
I think for me,
it was a little more
complicated than just the ACL.
And so, I was in bed
for at least two months.
And then non-weight
bearing after that
for another month or so.
And so, yeah.
But I think for me,
in recovery is just like
the faith thing helps me
because I know that there's
a purpose behind it.
And so, what I've learned
through getting injured
and being able to write
this book is like,
ultimately what God happens,
what happens good or bad,
God does have a purpose for it.
And there's a verse in
the Bible that says,
"All things work
together for the good,
to them that love God
and are called according
to his purpose."
So all I have to worry about
is loving God and aiming
to please him with my life.
And he's gonna make sure
that all the good and the
bad work towards my good.
And so, I see that
with this book.
I see that the people
leading the reviews
and it inspiring them.
And I got a message to
yesterday about a guy saying,
you know what?
I'm really gonna
pursue this faith thing
and figure out what a
relationship with Jesus Christ
because your book.
And so, I'm like, man,
okay, I can see
the purpose in it.
And so, with going through rehab
with the day-in,
day-out monotonous work
that does get
tiring and gruesome.
I'm like, man, there's a
purpose behind all of this.
And I just can't wait to
get back onto the court.
- How do you live a
life that's pretty,
from what I could tell,
pretty straight laced.
And I did meet your girlfriend,
who's fantastic.
Like compared to
what we think of,
say the average NBA
player out there,
partying all night,
going to strip clubs,
blah, blah, blah.
How do you kind of
grapple those two things,
like figure out
who your crew is,
and all that kind of thing?
- Well, I mean, I guess,
I just try to live my
life authentically.
Like I've experienced that.
Like I'm not one to say,
like I haven't,
wasn't the one that was going
to the clubs and drinking,
and do all the stuff I was.
And I got to experience
and I got to figure out
that it's empty, man.
It's not something
that can sustain you.
It's something that's
pleasurable for the moment.
And then you wake up and
your head is hurting,
and you gotta deal
with everything
that happened the night before.
And so, you know,
that there's a verse that says,
"Jesus came that
we may have life
and have life more abundantly."
And when I was doing
all those things
and living that early NBA life,
I really thought
that I was living.
And I really thought
that I had the life
that everybody wanted.
But what I've been
able to experience in
the last four years
in developing a
relationship with Christ,
like I wasn't even
close to living.
And being able to
do what I do now,
write a book and just see
my life kind of expand.
And I'm married now,
all those different things.
It's like, man, like,
it really is the truth.
And so I just try
to live my life.
But at the same time,
I have the right
people around me.
I have accountability
that helps keep me
strong and structured.
And I just kind of
keep my head down
and just keep moving forward.
- What do you wanna do when
the NBA thing wraps up?
(Jonathan chuckles)
- This is everybody-
- I sense something here.
- Yeah.
Listen, everybody
kind of, you know.
And I won't say everybody,
but a lot of people say,
you need to go on
and become a pastor,
all these different things.
But I'm always hesitant
to even affirm that,
just because I see firsthand
how difficult it is
and how high of a calling it is
to kind of shepherd
people through life.
But I mean, I wouldn't say no.
But I think right now,
I'm just trying
to figure out more
and more what God's
plan for my life.
I'm working on a second book.
The "Why I Stand"
book is being talked
about turning into a movie.
- Wow.
- And so there's just a lot
going on and I'm excited.
I just want to continue
to be a beacon of hope
for people who have
struggle with anxiety
and depression, and fear,
and let them know
that there is hope
in a relationship with Christ,
people who struggle
with suicide.
And just continue
to move forward.
Like I want to help the
world be a better place.
And I think the message of
Jesus Christ is how we do that.
And that's just where I'm at.
- By the way, we should mention,
so the Daily Wire, which
you mentioned before,
they are the
publishers of the book.
And is the movie going
through Daily Wire too?
Are you allowed to say?
- Yeah, yes.
So they're gonna be a part of
bringing the movie to life.
We're just still-
- Wow, awesome.
- Bringing it around
to other entities.
So we're figuring it out.
But I think it's
gonna be something
that's really
inspiring, really dope.
And you know, something
that a family can sit down
and watch, and be inspired by.
- I think people got
most of your message.
But is there any last
message I can offer them
or that you can offer
them that you want?
- Right now, "Why I Stand."
I got the book right here,
just so you guys can see it.
But yeah, go to Amazon, grab it.
Again, the book is so much more
than just about
standing in the bubble
and refusing a vaccine.
It really is a story
about my journey
and how I got to those
moments in the first place.
And so, I believe it to be
encouraging and inspiring.
And even if you're
not a Christian,
read the book and you
may walk away one.
But yeah,
so I just wanna encourage
people to go ahead and grab it.
It's doing great on Amazon.
We're gonna find out
tomorrow or Thursday,
if we made the New York Times
best sellers list or not.
So we're praying that we did,
but it's just an exciting time.
And again, just encourage
people to go grab it.
- I hate to tell you my friend,
as an old grizzled
veteran of books,
they should have put
me at number two.
They didn't put me on at all.
So the stats are not as
honest as basketball stats
when it comes to
the New York Times.
- I've definitely heard that.
And so we just,
I'm just, my hands are
up and just saying,
you know, what?
If it happens, it happened.
If it doesn't, it doesn't.
I'm excited either
way about the turnout
and you know what everybody's
saying about the book.
- New York times, basically,
you could have
36, 12, and eight.
And they'll say you
had 12, four, and two.
That's how it works, so.
(Both chuckles)
- I got you, I understand.
- Jonathan, you're awesome, man.
I hope to see you soon.
And I told you,
I got a pretty sweet
court down here in Miami.
So in that knees feeling good,
I think here's my prediction.
We're gonna play
horse at some point.
I think I can get an S on ya.
I think I can get
it as far to an S.
I can still shoot.
- Oh, wow, an S?
(Jonathan chuckles)
Okay, now, okay.
We definitely gotta
figure this thing out.
So when we play
Miami next season,
we'll figure it out.
- All right.
We're gonna make it happen.
It was great seeing you, man.
The link to the book
is right down below.
And I expect great
things at you, my friend.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our
politics playlists.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full
episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.